hey hey Glenn
yes
okay what we got a champ over here oh
yeah a real a CH uh
Champion they give me a medal on
everything yeah you have a trophy you
have a big trophy that you're gonna keep
in your home the trophy stays with the
club
um but they put a medal on me and I
could and at the moment now it was just
like like you know
um like uh when I got uh you know best
attendance in baseball uh it sure isn't
pal this is top of the league yeah right
but I guess what I mean is like do the
do is this a metal is this a tradition
uh for owners of teams in the league
that you're in to get a medal if you are
at the top of the league or did they
make a medal for you
and Ryan because you're you and Ryan
good question
we are very we are very aware of this
we're very aware of that and uh and I do
yes everybody gets a medal but I was
both excited in the moment when they put
it on I it was we were just elated but
it is a little bit embarrassing to be
wearing a medal right for something you
really didn't do well no no hang on a
second now now if you're the trainer and
you've taped people's ankles up all year
long uh for the you know Boston Red Sox
Sox won the World Series you get a World
Series ring you deserve that sucker
because you taped somebody's ankles yeah
you're part of a team effort okay what
is the team effort one thing if you if
you [__] up someone's ankle taping and
they [__] sprained their ankle like
uh trying what if you still score in the
final game and you don't win because
it's your if you still won and homeboy
Springs his ankle and you still get a
medal you're like because it's not just
because it's a team it's a team it's an
organization
Oscars are better than
um you know sport sports awards because
they're subjective arbitrary individual
and individual so not only are you
getting awarded for your imaginary
achievements uh you know you're getting
to take all the credit yeah well as an
actor one thing that we were that I'm
very cognizant of I I'm I always find it
creepy when they award the say the Super
Bowl trophy or the NBA Finals trophy or
uh or the World Series they give it to
the to the owners yeah and it always
creep me out yeah it's always a bad luck
Ryan and I were nowhere near even when
the guys were celebrating with the
champagne and everything we were like
this is their moment like they should
have it they're the ones that earned it
and then eventually you come in for them
because because that that's a good look
you know what I mean like well no it you
saw it was shot that way I mean yeah
yeah but maybe I can I can I can say
that on the documentary but I don't
think it needs to be said well now that
you're you've won the league yes right
right uh and you're going to be promoted
yes
um
what's going on with that stye I see
that it's it's gone it it was down here
when we were on the tour now that's such
an interesting thing to me it's it's the
little guy migrates the little the white
blood cells and all the guys that are
fighting the infection they were they
were down here even though they're
always supposed to be up here that the
guys that were trying to get them yeah
so so basically what's happening is that
the good guys are finally getting to
where they were supposed to be all along
yeah to fight the bad guys yeah and uh
man I just can't get rid of it now I
would think that the stress I don't feel
any more anxiety or stress so that so
now it's just a big ball of pus and uh
and blood you know it's cool you could
start like having
eye patches I thought of it you know
like you could like wear an eye patch
pretty sweet it'd be pretty sweet yeah
you could get like a wreck some eye
patch for when you're over there you
know what I mean no or just whatever
you're on camera badge on it yeah
promote the team
um yeah yeah that's that's not a bad
idea but you could like in this battle
that's going on inside there there could
be a a rexham level you know tier five
soccer level battle happening inside
your eye yeah wow think about that all
those little guys battling it out and
then at the end somebody might get a
medal
[Music]
thank you
what are the feelings what are the
emotions because you know obviously
we've had a lot of luck and success in
our careers and gotten to do some big
exciting things and we've gotten that
one-on-one relationship with the fans
when we tour around which is pretty
amazing
um describe the feeling of winning the
league of trying to do it and like and
how does it compare to other other
feelings that you found yes thank you uh
fair question
um you guys still have feelings there is
a there is a mod I'm assuming the moment
that we actually won the game
I I don't remember it all I kind of
blacked out I went because you know it
looked like you and Ryan almost fell
over the balcony yes like simultaneously
and I didn't and I didn't I didn't know
that until I until Paul because Paul
Rudd shot that because he was right
behind us and he showed us that video
and you see both of us at the same time
almost like collapse in unison yeah you
guys left our bodies
um and I don't remember doing that at
all and neither does he maybe something
entered your bodies from the back
[Laughter]
just consider it that's what I mean like
as opposed to something pulling out of
your body and pushing you forward that
could have been something that entered
you I think it was I think it was years
of I think it was a catharsis because
that was our stated goal and um it was
something that was and we talk about
this all the time
um in all sincerity if if Ryan and I
were to walk away from this we would be
fine
um because of uh so many different
reasons notwithstanding the reason that
we're sitting here right now but there's
a whole town
um that we promised two and a half years
ago to do our best to give them uh this
moment and and we didn't know how long
it would take a year two years five
years ten years
um we didn't know and we didn't know if
it would ever happen because that's kind
of the beauty of sport is that at the
end of the day you can put all the
pieces together but if it doesn't happen
out on the pitch it's not going to
happen so uh for for that moment to
happen uh I think for us was a
tremendous relief
because we feel like we've delivered on
our promises right
yeah that makes sense and you see how
the town reacted I mean yeah yeah sweet
thing yeah and I'm going back I'm going
back on Tuesday for 24 hours are you for
what uh they're having a big Civic event
we're gonna fly all the way over there
just for 24 hours it's worth it but it's
uh it's tough it'll be my eighth trip
this year it's hard to get to it's very
yeah
we're hard to get to from here maybe not
hard to get to from Liverpool but uh
definitely not hard to get to from from
Liverpool now are you flying into
Liverpool will you be flying into
Liverpool yeah it's it's it's always
tricky but um hopefully uh we have a
couple of new sponsors coming up this
this year and um four walls whiskey four
walls whiskeys yes but they're not gonna
help get me from Los Angeles to well no
we get a Liverpool Expressway paying all
the bills can we stopped on to talk
about the name Liverpool for a second is
it a pool full of livers is it I think
it's like something pulling up in your
liver that's what I think it is it's
yeah it's alcohol it's alcohol and it's
pooled up in your liver yeah I got a
question for you what if you're from
Liverpool you were called a liver
pudlian or so a liver pod land which is
the strangest this is crazy
yeah
somehow the pool got smaller
up the pool turned into a puddle I guess
why why would you be yeah why wouldn't
you be a liverpoolian a liver pandian
which sounds sort of alien but liver
pudlian doesn't sound that much less
alien so yeah so you're either a liver
puddling or
something else oh so you can be called
something okay I've only ever let me now
and this is sort of a it's a it's a
liver pipe I don't know where this came
from we'll have to look it up but Paul
Mullen our our Star Striker is liver
pudlian but he does not call himself a
liver pudley and he would call himself a
proper okay hold on wait don't don't say
it he's definitely a proper footballer
oh yeah he is a big god wow his
performance in that last game I mean his
performance the whole season just
incredible
um and such a lovely lovely lovely guy
the opportunity to to talk to him for a
solid 10 minutes after the game that the
match that we went to and I was just
struck at how
completely and totally down to earth he
was I mean there was nothing there's no
pretense there obviously but just so
such humility and all he wanted to talk
about was his family you know what I
mean like I don't know just such a
lovely guy they're all like that I mean
deliver puddly in way yes or the proper
yeah
oh that I would never yeah say what
Scout Scouts if you're if you're like uh
they say scouse why with a scouse a
scouse that also sounds like something
that some my pool guy would do right
Liverpool liver puddle like that a
scouser would come in and get the bottom
you gotta scouse the pool every so often
and get the algae yeah liver pipes that
are on the top of the pool yeah yeah
yeah before it puddles up
these are all related things because if
you ask me uh about how I feel and I I
think about Paul and I think about the
town I think about that experience it is
surreal you're you're standing up in
that box and they're singing songs to
you about you that was very surreal to
me also being there I'm like you know
this is my buddy that I've known for 20
years 20 plus no more than two oh my God
like 22 years you know who had to borrow
money from me at one point in order to
stay afloat and now there's a stadium
full of people's like cheering his name
super weird I to relieved like finally
like you're gonna be okay and we can
move on with our lives
well although it's just let us free
he might be leveraging himself to a
point let's go man I don't know no way
he might be yeah
yeah I know where my Bread's about it
I'll keep it
that's okay hey there's no one I'd
rather be trapped with power thank you I
feel the same way well but but truly so
you you see how what a surreal
experience that is and then amplify that
by a factor of 10 going through through
that through the winning of the league
and then just the surrealness of how
large it seemed like I was with Ryan and
Elton John called to talk like to
congratulations
like we were hearing from people I I
mean you know the the the the prime
minister of the UK gave us a shout out
today in Parliament
um we heard from the king I mean it's
it's bizarre and it's people are into
this into sports man a lot of Pride I
think Rippling throughout the entire
country right yes possibly clearing up
the device any divides any division
that's happening within the entire
country itself possibly possibly between
the North and the sun
um any why was Paul Rudd there well
it's so great this is so great well he's
an aunt he can make himself any size and
and I think move through the quantum did
he get stuck in someone's pocket I think
I think what happened was he actually
traveled through the quantum realm as
which is a much faster way
also fantastic but also Joe Russo was
there so Joe Russo who is not as famous
as Paul Rudd but directed two of the
biggest movies of all time certainly not
the number one and Titanic right no two
different guys those are two different
guys
oh uh yes the the most Star Wars
and Indiana Jones and the Raiders of the
Lost Art yeah you're swimming in this
these women in the same water yeah yeah
Paul uh came because uh he was shooting
Ghostbusters in London he's friends
so happened that he was planning to come
to this game and isn't it just like Paul
Rudd's life to just of course to show up
at that one yeah and we won the whole
thing
yeah I don't know not really he doesn't
he doesn't have a talk right no just uh
so you had Paul Rudd he had one Russo
brother yep you got a call from no
Anthony yeah we just Joe it was uh just
Joe yeah just join his family
nevertheless I mean just a a
Transcendent experience that's hard to
describe but to put it into some kind of
perspective I stayed out all night long
uh with the players trying to keep up
with their alcohol intake and I did
pretty well but um they're large young
men yeah and I got very drunk and had a
blast and then
were you on camera I was on camera the
entire time which is why I didn't say
anything stupid but you get the shirts
came off at one point and I was like
this is where the chairman keeps his
shirt on oh really yeah I would think
that the chairman could have taken his
shirt off when those guys get to be your
age they're gonna look like [__] and
I'll tell you why because they've been
doing all this running around and
training and then you know are they
gonna have the kids and they're gonna be
dealing with all that stuff and the life
stuff and they're not gonna have the
pressure of the camera constantly
pointing at them what you have which is
a good incentive to kind of keep your
[__] tight man sure it is it's it really
is it's good to take that camera away
you can just live your life yeah yeah
but also like you don't like if you
maybe if you did comedy your entire life
right and then you retired from Comedy
you're not gonna go home to your to your
Comedy Room in your giant house and do
more comedy right so these guys are
working out all the time right so once
they retire they're like oh God I
imagine you know they're like I don't
want to work out anymore I want to stop
now they're physical specimens they look
great like forever yeah yeah some of
them are so goddamn handsome and
charismatic and it just drives me crazy
I don't understand the the preponderance
of extraordinarily good-looking men in
in English football yeah
it's it's astounding how often I see a
person who's as talented as they are who
could also straight up be a male model
yeah and there's numerous examples of
that now they weren't all they're not
all like that let's be honest ghoulish
and awful to look at but they're
astounding to watch on the field you
know what I mean um but just the number
of them that that just so happened to
also be so incredibly good looking what
is that
I don't know they're the at a great age
right they're all 20 years old yeah so
that's when you're going to look pretty
good yeah but look I mean they're in
great shape I'm talking bone structure
I'm not just talking hairstyle I'm not
talking I'm talking like pure genetics
just handsome
give it time
give it time okay you know remember us
in our 20s some handsome fellas I don't
know some of those old episodes I'm like
I think we look better now but that's
just in some ways I feel like I I look
better now although things are you know
you start to see little things here and
there but we don't have to get into that
anyway the experience was uh was was
incredible and um I and I wasn't looking
for this long an answer it was just I
just like it was it was cool you know
you could have said like well I I'll
I'll I'll end it with this
um I'll end it with this because you
asked and I'll give you the I'll give it
to put it in perspective when I I flew
home after
the big celebration knowing I was going
to come back and um and hearing from
everybody and having thousands of emails
and texts in here and seeing it all over
the news and and then also having just
come off this like massive tour where we
were in front of tens of thousands of
people
and I landed back uh in La X and I came
home and um and there was nobody home
because the kids had gone out and they
were at Garden palooza I know exactly
where we go and I landed at home and um
and I had all this my bags and I had all
this laundry and I realized like oh I
gotta do the laundry because I'm not
gonna have clothes so so I was home
alone doing the laundry and I got a text
from Caitlin and she said can you feed
the dogs that's the reality yeah that's
the reality that's life well man I'm
sitting there and I'm doing my laundry
and I go down and I feed the dogs and
and I'm looking at the time and I'm
waiting for my kids to come home and
they come home and they're happy to see
me because they haven't seen me because
we were away for a couple weeks and then
we had dinner and I went to bed and woke
up the next day and took them to school
and because that's it if we keep
learning this lesson you hear the you
hear the the Behind the Music story of
the rise and fall of people all the time
and that [__] is real if you think that
standing up on that stage and hearing 10
000 people screaming for you or being up
in that box and waving like the queen
and having people sing to you is going
to make you happy you are [__] dead
wrong you're 100 you're 100 right if
that if that time where you're home
feeding the dogs doing your laundry
and then hanging out with your kids felt
like a letdown that would be a scary
thing right because because that those
are to be fair it does feel like a
letdown because just by like
biochemically you're you're all of that
serotonin that's like literally like
coursing through our bodies for those
three weeks you you feel that high that
just like depletes and your brain is
like wait where is that thing so I get
why people turn to drugs alcohol or like
the constant like adoration is because
you want your brain is going get that
thing back so if you're not cognizant of
it and we're lucky because we're in our
late four mid-40s where we can
internalize and then rationalize that
but if you if you don't if you can't
recognize like oh you feel a little down
right now but it's not because you don't
like your life it's not because you you
can't do your own laundry it's because
it's just a biochemical response and if
you can be grateful for the fact that
you get to come home to this family and
and you get to to also do those other
things that's where the the problem is
and so when you talk about Paul Mullen
like what a great example of a superstar
who can live in the Limelight but really
all he wants to do is talk about his
family yeah go home and play with this
because that's it you need the
foundation upon which to lay all that
other stuff and then everything else is
is really fun but it really is kind of
the ice I can't find it doing the
laundry
you know okay to be fair I'm not
suggesting that you I am happy if I've
got some good tunes on I'm happy to do
just about anything around the house but
I need the music
yeah I'm not suggesting that doing some
kind of like menial or manual labor
should be a joyous experience but if you
find yourself thinking that you're above
it yeah you don't belong there where you
actually belong pick up dog [__] you're
still gonna have diarrhea at one point
in your life and how cool are you then
although Joe was talking about getting a
third dog and she was like if we get a
third dog I think we should hire one of
those people that comes over and picks
up your dog [__] and I was like can we
please not be those people yeah that
hire someone to come although I did
spend like I love dog [__] that they
generate
it's astounding it's astounding I spent
like 45 minutes the other day cleaning
up dog [__] yeah and then they call and
then the dogs ran outside and [__] like
five more times I was like we're so we
don't like you know like if a kid's
coming over to play with my son like
I'll go in the backyard make sure like
you gotta like cleaners can be and then
10 minutes later I'll do another little
Loop and be like when did these guys
what I didn't even see who is it I was
out here when were you this is more
humbling than having to pick up the
defecation of another season yes you
have another species I'm gonna pick this
poop up and put it in a bag yeah yeah
and then I'm gonna have to wash my
[__] hands you wash your hands
afterwards I do because the bags have a
scent to them and you're you just feel
you just feel dirt now were you guys
using the biodegradable yes okay good
good good good good just want to check
on that because they make some really
good ones and I want to make sure that
that's that we're all doing the right
thing here oh yeah I'm [__] and hand
sewing a [__] mitten and uh throwing
that no
well anyway anyways all good stuff I
guess we should talk about the I'm gonna
I just I just as a little foreshadowing
I I was alone in the hotel and I I hit a
certain point where I was like I'm just
so bored and the TV's not working and I
had a link to Glenn's movie and I know
we're gonna save it we're going to watch
David we're going to save it I'll save
it I'll save it have you watched it I'm
going to watch it uh tonight right I'll
be talking tomorrow we're talking Friday
about it get it strap in baby I'm so
excited I've been like I had to withhold
from texting you or calling you right
after I saw it I almost stopped a
halfway to call you and I was like save
it for the positive but I have now I'm
seeing you in person and I gotta tell
you strap in I can't wait I can't well I
I can't wait to talk about it it seems
like what you're saying is that you
enjoyed it and you enjoyed my
performance so I appreciate it that
fills me up you're filling me up right
now okay
I love it when you fill me up okay good
well there's nothing better than being
filled up by your friends yeah right
getting filled up yeah plug in those
holes you know what I mean plugging
those God holes filled to the brim
[Music]
hey what are we talking about now
for the fellas this one's for the fellas
where my guy bosses no girls allowed huh
this is
for the dude
dudes all right all right all right all
right uh now that none of the women are
listening gentlemen level with me
has the Thunder Down Under
gone quiet
are you going for gasps but only getting
laughs oh oh no so what you do is you go
to bluetooth.com and and you consult
with the a licensed medical provider
that they have and you get approved for
a prescription and then bam dude
your boner pills straight to your door
they should just pop a BC on there on
the box right so that everyone knows
guys are you can't say boner pills it
has to be boner tablets oh okay sorry
um are you serious
yeah yeah okay uh boner tablets okay
yeah all you do is go to bluetooth.com
right you speak with one of their
licensed medical providers you get a
prescription uh for Bluetooth and then
bam you get your boner tablet straight
to your door now Bluetooth wants to help
you have better sex discover your
options at bluechoo.com chew it and do
it and we've got a special deal for our
listeners okay try Bluetooth free when
you use our promo code Sunny free
free just try it it's free when you use
the promo code sunny at checkout and
just pay all you gotta do is pay the
five dollar shipping okay so that's
bluetooth.com promo code Sunny uh and
you're gonna get your first month free
if you visit bluetooth.com for more
details important safety information and
we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast thanks Bluetooth and uh and uh
enjoy your boners everybody yep
[Music]
so let's talk about It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia let's talk about a little
bit so by the way Megan's not here yeah
Megan is not here she went to Amsterdam
to do drugs and hang out in the red
light district I'm sure but Mara's back
at work Mars back because uh she made it
out but Megan needed a few extra days
getting high yeah just getting Stony
baloney and doing mushrooms doing
mushrooms and
yeah possibly doing stuff in the red
light district
are you suggesting she's selling it or
buying it well I listen I'm not
suggesting it depends on which drugstore
I don't assume anything especially about
other people I don't assume anything
ever
I make no assumptions
it makes an ass out of you and me yes
yes it does and I don't even talk about
the things that I see because what if
I'm not seeing it right
according to other people that's right
that's right so I'll stick to my Lane
here let's talk now because Megan's not
here I gotta sort of be the the and I
know that you're the host I'm gonna be
the host a little bit today thank you
please do okay now we don't even have to
get to any of this because maybe we can
just
you know do what we always do which is
just talk and talk and talk yeah news
flash great episode oh man oh man
because it was last minute I watched I
had to watch it this morning I watched
it last night I watched it last night
with Mary Elizabeth oh you did oh yeah
of course yeah yes it was fun I wish he
could have been here
I invited her but you know she didn't
want to adjust your schedule around it
so the podcast waits for no one yeah
that's right this is the podcast waits
for nobody although it did wait a couple
weeks for us to get through our [__]
didn't it well it's for us it's Gotta
Wait for us we're the ones we're the
conductors we're the conductors of that
there's a lot of scheduling just to get
three of us here so it sure is it sure
is totally worth it totally worth it um
I I'm with you man I I was uh uh kind of
giggling my balls off watching this ton
of fun a lot of a lot of things we
establish here like Frank and artemis's
relationship yeah oh so yeah right this
is the first time we established that
now am I mistaken in thinking that
Danny's only in like I can only think of
him being in two scenes in this movie I
mean in this episode the uh the the the
back off the second scene back from
commercial uh back from the opening
titles when we're in the back office and
then the scene in Dee's apartment is he
in anything else that might be right
yeah and yet he's so so incredible even
just the way he's in that first office
scene the way he hangs up the phone as
we're walking in it is a sense of like I
have a secret but also like kind of
proud and kind of prideful almost like
wanting us to ask him about it like so
many different things happening there on
this one I missed that Savage Savage
Savage it's a great structural episode
yeah it is yes yeah
yeah the ending is very satisfying but I
get we'll start at the beginning it's
like two almost two a stories right like
both stories have equal importance and
they're both super interesting and weave
together nicely and they weave together
nicely oh sorry I also got to do a shout
out for my my close close friend Nick
Wexler who plays Brad Fisher
um a guy
who is almost exclusively known for
working in dramas uh mostly on
television does almost nothing but
dramas and yet is one of the funniest
people I've ever met in my entire life
and is dying to do more comedy and is is
super super funny
D Reynolds
yeah Brad Fisher from high school Brad
Fisher no way you look amazing your acne
cleared up really well I kind of grew
into myself I did yes you did why did I
ever break up with you it was because of
the acne yeah uh when it got real bad
you dumped me and you said it was
because I was going to grow up to look
like Edward James Olmos I don't really
remember saying exactly that it's it's
fine we were kids we were kids we were
kids yeah anyway love Nick Wexler yeah
um
yeah it starts with Naseem pedrod
pre-snl right I believe it was just pre
just before she got the show yeah yeah
and you every once in a while we'll have
uh in fact the entire guest cast in this
episode is fantastic and a lot of them
are supporting the characters that have
come back but everybody it kills and
every once in a while and including
what's her name Joy osmanski yes Joe
the three of us are dynamic in this
episode is so fun it feels to me like
almost like when we started the show
firing on all cylinders with that with
the three-man relationship in this one
yeah yeah
motivation
that is so simple you know so it's
really just a a very sort of just honest
exchange of ideas
that and there's clash with each other
two things that happen in this episode
early that we we've we have addressed
that we did this early and then stopped
doing it
um both one of which is we explain why
we're about to do something like very
clearly why we're gonna help why do we
have to help Charlie well because he's
good we're afraid he's going to go
postal if we don't right as opposed to
just helping Charlie which adds although
I would argue in this particular case it
it does add sort of stakes to it whereas
which is hopefully why we left it in not
just because we felt well I think this
needs more justification than some of
our crazy stuff because the characters
are so self-centered we needed to
justify why you guys were gonna do a
nice thing you know that you had a
self-centered motivation to do it yes
for it to not in fact we called D out
for that very thing she says that's
really funny because I was I watched her
first line where she's like guys we got
to think about Charlie and I was like oh
wow we're kind of writing like season 1
D there and then we pull the rug out
from under him like oh yeah good good
yeah because she's worried that he's
gonna she's gonna have to do this
Charlie were yeah she's gonna have to do
the Charlie work right and oh right
right casual
casualists casualness that you guys are
um
talking about my character committing
suicide being like well he's definitely
gonna commit so when he does when he
does when he commits it's gonna be a
problem for all of us yes it is yeah by
the way guys
I forgot to introduce the episode that
we're talking about today maybe we could
cut this in earlier or not uh phone's
off
she's falling apart without Meg okay
this so this is a little segment we like
to call that is what happened
season five episode five
uh the waitress is getting married aired
on October 15 2009 it was written by
Charlie Day and Glenn Howerton
two of my favorite people and directed
by Fred Salvage
special guest stars Nick Wexler as Brad
Joy osmanski wow
as Jackie I did that's weird
oh that's so weird maybe recall is
incredible Naseem pedrod as Lucy who
works in the wedding dress store again
shout out to Naseem but also shout out
to her sister Nina pedrod who was a
writer on uh new girl for a very long
time and has become one of our writers
and has directed uh and director of an
episode this season yes yes uh love love
love them both summary Dee tries to stop
the waitress from marrying their Mutual
ex-boyfriend Mac and Dennis helped
Charlie start and uh start online dating
and Frank and Artemis explore their
Newfound food fetish
boy what a wonderful show this is guys
let's pop this off Let's Get It Started
what do you guys want to talk about with
regards to this episode we'll cut that
in earlier and then it'll all flow I
think we leave it right where it is
um
your hair is looking good yeah
you put some sort of activator in it and
you know I used a different I used a
different shampoo it's this stuff called
oh what's it called It's Just For Men no
no no no no
well that would be the color wouldn't it
no it's this stuff that's um what's it
called new oh [__] but it's that she is
jizz that's what it was I washed my hair
in jizz
um it's this stuff it doesn't foam up
and it's it's like I don't know it was
given to me by uh Happy children on our
show okay like a long time ago and I'd
never tried it I tried it for the first
time and I'll tell you something I woke
up this morning and and my hair was a
little bit had a little bit more curl to
it yeah there's a curl there's a little
bit of a curling to the top but like
what's that only on the top top I don't
know you don't have enough on the sides
some kind of thickening serum as well it
looks great no no no well I have been I
do use one of those Capella's caps as
we've yes as we've uh established well
we haven't established on the podcast
one of those red light therapy things
right just to keep the hair laser hat
that's called we call it a laser hat
that's not what it is but it's fun to
call it that that's what my wife calls
it
[Laughter]
Stars they're just like us they use
laser they're using their laser there
you go I'm bragging about doing my
laundry and feeding my dogs
yeah the laser hats available to the
general public it's just it is a little
cost prohibitor it can be quite
expensive but listen if you want a full
head of hair and you want your you know
your friends and your co-workers to
compliment you on your beautiful curly
hair the next morning you gotta go get
yourself lasered a laser hat you don't
want the cheap lasers
um now the episode the episode do you
want you want me to ask you guys some
questions yeah what do you got okay I
got some questions
I asked as I was walking in I I asked
Mara and Chloe if they could possibly
figure out a way to transcribe one of
the scenes from the episode then maybe
we could act it out
because it could be fun do we have that
I don't know if we have that yeah you
want to step on camera here
so you you we're doing we're gonna do
one of those
um things where we recreate the scene
yeah by the way I love I have to
compliment uh Nick Wexler on his
delivery like you know uh Caitlyn goes
nordego's uh why did we bring he comes
in right at the end it was because of
the acne was it because of the acne I
love that exchange the timing of that is
just within that scene where they come
over for the date night or the the party
and
Caitlyn is just like saying all these
horrible things she's like wow you're
making all that up right here yeah yeah
um having sex for I love Caitlin the
scene where she stops the car apparently
she's just driving your car which is a
funny thing that we're like I guess she
took Dennis's car oh and she stops it in
the middle of the road to get out that's
how people do in Philly because the
streets are so narrow oh it's hilarious
that people will just stop and then get
out and go do whatever they have to do
because there's nowhere to park there's
no oh my God I had a gun yesterday
somebody else and I were driving it down
Los felos Boulevard a guy does that uh
he gets out of his car
I don't know for what reason and he's
looking at his side door well the car
behind thinks [__] this guy I'm gonna
try to swerve around but when the car
pulls to the left to swerve around the
guy another truck is coming
in in that left lane and hits a breaks
as hard as it can and stops just before
hitting the car trying to get around if
it had hit the car it would have pushed
the car forward smashing the guy who got
out to look at his [__] car so that
guy
almost almost died just like he escaped
narrowly escaped a crushing he narrowly
escaped to crushing this would have
turned into a little liver puddle
right
instantly puddled yeah and uh that would
have been it and had to scouse him right
off the street so guess what if you
remains a pool of Scouts they'd have to
scouse they'd get it the scouts are out
there in the middle of traffic uh don't
get out of your car you know I just go
ahead and pull over and look at whatever
you got to look at don't just stop your
car in the middle of a a road that where
people are going you gotta and if if a
guy's done that in front of you take a
second before you try to swerve around
him you know what I mean just look life
advice that's what we're doing
better if the guy did get crushed and
killed but not better for him but more
interesting for the fans yeah
um right uh here and here come the
papers
if it comes by everybody she looks great
[Applause]
did you put the leather jacket on just
for that answer she's sobering up
because
are you still high
this is the dating profile scene a
simple scene you guys are just coming
over uh to put me on a dating website
and I am a strange man and it doesn't go
well yep
um okay so Charlie uh yeah we're gonna
get you back on the dating scene bro
what do you think about that yeah yeah
that's actually why we're here we want
to we want to put your profile on
match.com now wait a minute hold on I
gotta stop down for a second here this
was a match.com thing we did have a
little plug like a little now was that
because was that because of the concept
of the episode and somebody came to us
and said hey let's do some product
integration I think it was like that
yeah we had the episode idea and they
were like hey this is great we could
also could you plug match.com we're like
absolutely sure we'll make money for you
and not for us or it was none of that
and we didn't get paid at all I mean we
didn't get paid well no we didn't we
never get paid we never get paid but we
didn't we got not sued it was so
yeah right yeah but yeah you know uh
totally but you know we we thought
um you know you know we think that you
could meet somebody new yeah someone you
like even more than the women yeah I
don't really see how that's possible but
um
all right tell you what uh you know let
me pop a quick h on this box uh that way
we all know it's full of hornets and
stuff so it'll have an H on it
okay well Deanna do what you got to do
and then we'll uh we'll get started yeah
all right good to go okay these things
sting like a [__] so you want to have
an H on there yeah you sure do yeah they
are hornets yeah okay watch out with
that box with B on it
what is that those are just pieces yeah
right I should have put that together
okay all right well listen uh let's get
to it all right first thing we got to do
we gotta we do we need to take your
picture for the profile so yeah so do
you have the makeup yeah uh yes yeah
let's let's cover this up here yeah okay
well I don't know come on no makeup guys
none of those things are pretty they're
pretty bad buddies so I think we gotta
have to who I am right but let's do who
you are minus the Hornets yeah like
let's pretend like you're not who you
are and just try to attract a woman yeah
I'll get like a checkered hat and a pipe
and like that would work
what what why why would you want to a
checkered hat I don't understand what is
that for the Sherlock Holmes look you
know how he always he has like a
checkered Hattie as like a little you
know like okay pipe not a cob pipe not a
cheap pipe like a nice pipe a nice one
yeah well why would you want to look
like Sherlock Holmes like what what is
that track intelligent women okay yeah
right now without the makeup we'll see
if she snagged that we'll see if he'll
see if he likes that
[Laughter]
you know
yeah we'll deal with that later we'll
fix him post well yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah we're gonna
I can see I can see where this is headed
so let's just let's not do that right
now let me take another one no no I
don't think so you got a good one no
well we got one let's start then okay
we'll we'll find another picture and
that'll be fine let's talk about let's
talk about your likes and dislikes
what's your what's your favorite food
for instance what would that be sure
definitely milk steak
uh milk steak you know I'm not putting
milk steak what even is that yeah just
put steak just put regular steak yeah I
don't know what a milk regular steak and
put milk steak otherwise she's not gonna
know what it is no no she won't know
what it is nobody knows what that is
it's uh okay okay perfectly clear I
don't know how no it sounds clear but
nobody knows what it is because it's not
a thing okay all right all right let's
what's what's your favorite hobby uh
magnets
okay uh what like like making magnets
collecting magnets magnets you know like
regular magnet stuff
no no no magnet is I'm just saying what
are you doing or like sometimes they
push each other away from each other
okay you know what I'm gonna put
snowboarding we'll put uh let's put
snowboarding sounds like a snowboard but
okay how do you magnet
you stick them or you push them apart
from one another
and that's your hobby
yeah
I don't think I've ever seen it never
seen okay all right I don't even eat a
magnet I don't do you know I don't like
trying to show off and do it all the
time in front of you guys
show off okay listen let's move past
that um why don't we what are some of
your likes schools for sure okay what
are you talking about what are you
talking about now oh it's like a little
you know little green ghouls like you
know funny little funny little green
like movies like in cartoons
I'm not gonna write ghouls I'm not
writing it I'm putting travel Jesus
Christ travel I don't like traveling Oh
what are your dislikes I want a girl who
likes School uh people's knees come on
dude I'm gonna be walking around
everywhere I don't want to see people's
knees what is it let's okay
let's just get out of here no we can't
do this all right we're not even gonna
we're not even gonna use you for this
yeah we got that we got the picture all
right but you're not gonna get a cool
chick if you know you're not putting all
my cool things down and that's
you're walking around the world shooting
that scene was so fun because we didn't
know how we're gonna say we don't know I
can't remember if some of it was in
profit I think it was prescription it
was scripted but it was loose loose
loose yeah yeah uh and just you know
getting to try to trip you guys up and
then your reaction to it you know the
the that's what's so funny about it just
how you guys react to these absurd
answers yeah it's such a blast to uh to
shoot that scene
um the concept of uh ghouls
now where that came from was when I was
a kid
um we had this book uh this Halloween
book and I believe I think it was called
it's Halloween and it was a book of like
little like Halloween poems and and all
these like little Halloween stories and
I just remember this one story like
really standing out to me where there
was like a ghoul sitting on a sitting on
a tree outside of this kid's window and
the kid didn't know why the ghoul was
there and uh and and just thinking that
that was a funny I don't know why but I
I don't know why but I remember it
striking me that that would be a funny
thing for Charlie to like there's
something funny about just like it's not
a it's not a ghost it's not a goblin
it's not a goblin it's a ghoul it's a
ghoul it has there's a sense of Mischief
to it
what in your mind would be the
difference between a goblin and a ghoul
a goblin just wants trouble we're a
ghoul okay goblins a goblin wants
trouble and a Goblin's gluttonous and
there's nefarious and up to zero good
the goal is also up to no good but has a
sense of humor about it yeah he wants it
to be he wants it to be he mostly needs
to be fun for him so he's gonna like
switch your socks around and you know
it's silly put something for you to trip
over and sure yeah he's silly he's silly
silly he might bite you yeah
I gotta keep trying to catch him you
squeeze him too tight he's gonna bite
your finger you know but uh where are
the goblins its sole purpose is to bite
you yeah Goblin you really can't trust
right a goblin Goblin's horrific the
thing the goblin you even spot the
goblin doing his thing and you're you're
in trouble right away you're gonna have
to run yeah yeah yeah Goblin could kill
you ghouli could probably kick it across
the room
right yeah
yeah man you know what's funny
feel like you're right no
and that's gonna stink up your apartment
for days the goals are relatively
odorless
[Laughter]
[Music]
watching and listening to this right now
is doing what I'm doing which is I'm
picturing both of them in my head
pretty good idea let me tell you let me
ask this is the cool bald yes yeah the
Goblin's balls it's bald that is green
it's definitely green yeah and it's bony
and it's it's gross the ghoul is I see
the gold green I see the gold screen it
was awesome in my mind has has a smaller
but has like kind of a a round body but
very skinny legs
um but I might just because it's got big
ears yeah
yeah yeah and a scowl yeah the gold is
almost like a gnome
you know but not quite like a gnome are
you picturing a beard
no no beards the beard in the Hat yeah
oh maybe he does have a hat it might
have an a hat of shorts but it could be
one of your socks that it's stolen the
stuff that out
[Applause]
hey guys guess what this show was
sponsored by Better Health betterhelp is
an online therapy service that is
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule and we could all
use that in this day and age something
that's more suited to our schedules
because everybody's busy I'm so busy
right now I can't even find time for
myself I feel like we keep getting
busier and busier and busier what does
Glenn need for himself what do you need
do you need a vacation you need uh just
to go on a walk what what are you
seeking I want it all yeah
oh [__]
[Laughter]
oh God no no a vacation is work these
days I mean so many so many emails to
send right you're on vacation you're
like looking here I gotta answer these
emails
vacations are basically like work
Retreats these days that seems like
something you should bring up with a
therapist so then does work actually
feel more relaxing to you than a
vacation well like I said don't take
vacations anymore because they are
basically work and in a way neither does
better help that's part of how their
vast network of licensed professionals
Works to fit into your schedule so you
can always get help when you need it and
learn tools to find better balance in
your life oh man you know why I know
that I need better help in my life
because right now I just want to get
back to my computer because I know
there's emails just ding ding ding ding
ding ding right and I just it's the
stress of it I need I need I need
therapy no let's let's find more balance
in our life right why don't you use
better help yeah absolutely so visit
betterhelp.com Sunny to get 10 off your
first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash Sunny
[Music]
a lot of questions here we don't have to
get to them all uh but D dumps Brad
because of his acne now what was the
worst reason you ever dumped someone or
got dumped in high school worst reason
yeah
that's what sucks about getting dumped
not because you like oh I I said the
dumb thing at the party in the dumped me
like she liked you fundament she
disliked you fundamentally yeah you get
dumped because they the person decides
yeah you're not good enough for what I
want that's the worst reason right I can
do better that's the only reason I know
yeah you've been relegated that's why
I've been promoted yeah it's it's a
wholesale rejection oh it's not well if
you were just a little bit it's
something you could work on no no no
you're not attracted to you that's why
it hurts yeah that's why it hurts and
that's why physically mentally
spiritually yeah I want you until time
passes and then you're like
I don't give a [__] about you either I
just didn't want you that's the
Revelation isn't it yeah it happens
later it happens later later we're like
I just want to be wanted I don't
necessarily want the person that's
stomping me yeah you know it doesn't
need to be it doesn't need to be you
right you get your sights set on
something and you forget the fact that
compatibility is important right because
when you're younger you're just like ooh
I like that I want that right and then
you don't realize that you don't you
don't you and then when that that
person's like yeah but I don't want that
and I don't want you you go
how do I get you to like me and want me
you know it's just like guys this is not
how it works you know tough time in life
oh boy well you've all been with your
spouses for many years now
but did any of you have the chance to
try online dating before you met them no
no this is what's so cool we're so crazy
so old we didn't have any online dating
well on no maybe you did a little bit no
no no I didn't I well
there's some Myspace encounters I all I
talk about with with younger people or
even people outrage who are newly single
uh and they all [__] about oh it's
Tinder or um is it what's the most
popular one to Raya Tinder they're
they're uh they're the worst it's the
worst all you do is just meet people at
a brand Bangles
random sex with like people you're
attracted to it's science it sucks I
don't want this oh my God she's super
hot I get to [__] her that's horrible
is where people are looking for for
other people that for us was called the
world and you just it was a toss-up
whether people were looking for you
could be like hey are you looking for a
person they're like no I'm not looking
for a person at all versus the app and
you know you're looking for uh you would
enter a physical space and you would
swipe the person out of your way to get
to the person behind them you know what
I mean [__] swipe out of my way I'm
trying to get to the SpongeBob jerk
swipe off Google yeah yeah oh sorry well
that button that but that could take
hours days weeks months years whereas
you can just do it it's a I've it's
amazing it's amazing now does it lead to
long-term relationships I don't know I'm
not of course sometimes it could of
course but then you probably also get
the real-time rejection which I don't
know what that feels like but if you're
like constantly trying to meet people on
those apps and they're all being like
hey
now that Mustang it doesn't feel as
personal as when it happens you know
when you're when you're in in the club
or in the club or in the bar and it
happens and they and they swipe you
right in front of your [__] face
I was usually pretty good with that I
just moved on but yes you were and I I
was mortified by rejection you numbed
yourself to it because it was a numbers
game it was just the numbers
sure yeah and as the night got on as the
night got on and people judgment you
know got a little bit and they're like
well maybe he is taller than I think
you'd wait it out
yeah yeah well the handsome ones are go
the tall handsome ones are gone yeah
yeah and the problem is like those clubs
wherever you would go wherever people
would go to meet you after completion
yeah it was so loud so I couldn't even
do what I couldn't even like speak it
was all just based on the way people
looked oh yeah that's why that's why I
didn't like the club I wasn't much of a
dancer I didn't want to like dance I
didn't have the right clothes for the
club most of the time I couldn't even
get into the club and even when I did I
didn't want to be there that is the
worst feeling in the world to stand
outside of a club that you don't even
want to be in and then get rejected yeah
yeah yeah like I don't you want to tell
the bouncer like I never I didn't want
to come here but that's my beauty of the
online dating the only reason we were
going there the club's in your pocket
yeah the club the club is right here bud
oh the club is right here now I do I can
understand that just like say you know
human beings just adapt to what whatever
it is so for us it seems cool and
amazing that you have that level of
accessibility but my guess is you do it
long enough you get used to it and then
it doesn't fit it doesn't it doesn't uh
it's it's less satisfying right it's
it's I don't know sometimes I think it's
better if you got to work for it a
little bit a little harder right it just
starts to feel
I don't know a little uh even more
superficial than what it was when we
were when we were kids out there in the
club and uh desperately trying to you
know hit on
just people we wanted to make love to
yeah you know just meet people
yeah get out in the world and you know
but yeah swipe and get swiped in person
for God's sakes right that's the lesson
here so the next episode will be uh
talking about Charlie's uh directorial
debut
a movie written directed
by and starring Mr Charlie Day
so exciting one of my favorite people
one of my favorite people one of my
favorite performers one of my favorite
writers and I'm getting double taped
it's pretty great and possibly one of my
favorite directors although that remains
to be spoken about we have not spoken
about your directorial skills so we can
get in and talk about that I'm very
excited to talk to you about that movie
uh I have not seen the most recent
version of it I'm very excited to see it
I've only seen an older version of it uh
and also ha you know had multiple
conversations about uh you know how the
ones the the scene that I'm going to be
in is yeah anyway
um several scenes uh and then uh we'll
talk about uh Blackberry starring Glenn
Howerton uh a movie where uh
you deliver a performance that is being
talked about well you know our
expectations low just keep them low I'm
sure it's great because mine were high
and news flash [__]
they were met they were Mary Elizabeth
saw it at South by Southwest and was
talking about hungry right right
everyone's talking about how great you
are because you're great and and these
directors had the good sense to give you
the opportunity to let you do what you
do which Hollywood should do more of
so I'm excited to get into that and all
and a little jealous of two things one
that that I'm not the person delivering
this performance to the world of course
right um and and two that our movies are
coming out on the same goddamn day
unbelievable but it doesn't matter it's
not about what happens in the box office
or who goes he's what it's about the
fact that we're making the art that we
want to make what if it becomes about
that how for me man I'm not gonna let
uh
what happens outside of the movie
dictate to me what the experience of the
movie is yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um it's like look at signing it's a
perfect example right like uh you know
uh the the doing the sunny is the sunny
going to those shows with thousands of
people screaming they're screaming about
things we did 10 years ago yeah well
look you know everybody please just get
you know get out there and watch both
movies they're both very very different
different movies and I haven't seen them
both although not the newest version are
both uh I'm very proud of of these films
so you know save it don't save it I'll
save it don't let don't don't let the
fact that both Charlie and I are in two
different movies Glenn's in both movies
so it's a win-win for Glenn it is kind
of a win-win for me although it's a
win-win for me too pal the fact that the
movie is out to the world and in the
theater here we go we're gonna talk
about that I'm excited to talk about it
this is all I'm excited to talk about it
thank you
[Applause]